hey do you want to go elf spotting in
Iceland well there's a map for that I
mean look at this thing isn't this
amazing this is a map that was created
by a graduate student and a professor at
the University of Iceland and it shows
the location of Elf sightings from a
database of hundreds of years of
folklore oh and it's not just in the
past people still claim to see these
elves in Iceland today they call them
the holdafolk or hidden people I've been
to Iceland a couple of times and I kind
of understand why these stories persist
this place is truly magical this
Supernatural looking landscape of
rolling Mossy Hills glaciers lava fields
and beaches According to some surveys
over half of Icelandic people believe
that elves exist or at least that it's
possible that they exist now caveat to
this we don't know how seriously
Icelandic people actually take this
belief but these headlines definitely
contribute to the country's booming
tourism industry where incidentally you
can go on a guided tour of culturally
significant elf regions but if you want
to go on a self-guided tour there's a
map for that